Sarah Chen:
Hi, I'm Sarah.
Chenyu Zheng:
I'm Chenyu.
Kelly Rouser:
I'm Kelly.
Chenyu Zheng:
And we are the organizers of the sustainable fashion contest.
Sarah Chen:
We gave very loose guidelines to any student
designers who wanted to enter.
Sarah Chen:
Really we just asked them to create pieces out of anything
that could be re-used, that could be deemed sustainable.
Chenyu Zheng:
We were also fortunate to collaborate with the Art Museum,
which provided a special venue for the event.
Chenyu Zheng:
The format of the contest was each contestant would
come up to the stage and present his or her piece,
Chenyu Zheng:
and then all four judges will ask questions.
Kelly Rouser:
So, one of the judges was Professor Patricia Brown.
Another judge was senior James Mister, and he's in
Kelly Rouser:
the Politics department.
And then a third judge was Nina. All I know was that she
Kelly Rouser:
was a fashion designer, so we just happened to meet her while
preparing for the competition.
Kelly Rouser:
And the fourth judge was Starre Varten, and she's the
eco-blogger that we invited earlier to speak during dinner.
Student:
So, the biggest problem with type 6
plastic is it has a very narrow window of when it's
Student:
melting and then when it goes past the point that it can
be heated and becomes brittle and unusable.
Student:
So, what I was interested in, because I do a lot of material
science, would be... was trying to find the point at which it
Student:
would slump and soften while still retaining
its malleability.
Student:
So, I wanted things that were beautiful and
thought-provoking but were also, at a very basic level,
Student:
practical and functional.
Chenyu Zheng:
And one art major, she used the used, leftover
canvas from her art studio.
Chenyu Zheng:
So, it's all leftover material that happened
to be thrown away into the trash.
Chenyu Zheng:
And one student, she used her own thesis.
Laura Bai:
I like to think of this as like a quintessentially
Princeton piece, because, well first you have the thesis, but
Laura Bai:
also a lot of people tend to drink a lot of caffeinated
beverages at Princeton.
(music)
Student:
So it was very much we were constantly bantering and
checking things out with each other, trying shoes
Student:
on for each other.
Very collaborative, the whole process, but tons of fun.
Student:
That's really the key. It was a project that we saw going into
it, going, "Wow, this could be a lot of fun for us to do, a way
Student:
to spend time and hang out, and that's what it should be about."
I think it's going to be kind of a major catalyst in
Student:
my life, both as a designer and as a chemist, because it really
reinforced what I've always suspected, which is that I
Student:
fundamentally love the design and materials, especially as
tied to their functionality, and I've always thought that I
Student:
was really most interested in architectural materials, and I
could -- after this experience -- I could really see myself going
Student:
into the design of fashion materials and maybe the
design of the fashion itself.
(music)